[Music]
thank you peter for joining us now peter
you're one of the few people who've seen
roads to freedom since it last aired on
television for viewers who aren't
familiar with it at all can you explain
a bit about the show what it's about and
kind of why it's so important
well it's a marvelous crisp concise
dramatization of jean-paul satra's
enormous trilogy the rose to freedom
which
which
covered the the last months of peace
set in left-back paris and is full of
all kinds of extraordinary events and
philosophical discussions about human
freedom you wouldn't have thought it was
it was filmable but it was brilliantly
filmed one of the first things the bbc
ever filmed in color in that rather nice
artistic greenish color they used to do
things in back in the 60s and it aired
in 1970 just at the very end of the 60s
as they were slipping forever uh away
from us and
i i am a huge number of other people
watched it completely enthralled
and it left a great impression on my
mind not least the the actual the theme
music the the song which was sung at the
opening and the closing of each
of each episode uh wrote the uh la route
europe by sung by georgie brown
and
many years later
thinking
that it might be interesting to see it
again when a lot of old tv programs are
re-emerging
i i've made some inquiries and found
this extraordinary story about it it
does exist
but it can't be shown it was shown once
to an audience of the british film
institute
about 10 years ago
over a weekend but it's it can't
apparently be shown on television the
bbc are terribly evasive if you ask them
why not and they say they have no plans
to show it but we know it exists and
there it is so i
having written a bit about this mystery
in my mail on sunday column uh i was
invited through a series of secret
meetings and passwords and speak easy
arrangements to actually see it and so
eventually did
and it is as i thought it would be the
most extraordinary evocation of the last
years of the 1960s and also a very
satisfying piece of drama it's a great
shame it can't be shown but i think i
can see why i mean some of our viewers
might be asking fairly you know the bbc
has thousands of shows in its archive
you know it can't show all of them is it
is it just a procedural cost kind of
thing why it can't be shown do you think
or do you think there's something more
going on there
well i think there's something more
going on i can't prove it but i think
it's very interesting things a huge
difference between what the radical left
was like in 1970 and what it's like now
and there's a particular character
daniel played by the fantastic actor
daniel massey
who is a homosexual character and he's
portrayed very much as years in in
saatra's
book uh as a
as a man who strongly dislikes himself
and a lot of what he does
and also has rather
ambivalent feelings when the nazis
eventually arrive in paris which are not
really greatly to his credit
and i think that the bbc
probably fear that if they showed this
that a lot of people would think that it
was
it was saying something that it wasn't
saying look we all nobody speaks about
these things as they spoke about them in
1970 anyway
but there was something about that
character who's immensely important in
in the whole series which i think they
they think would bring them trouble from
from from modern radicals and so a very
radical program now can't be shown i
think because of the fear of what modern
radicals would make of it great pity it
is a great watch yeah i mean you
mentioned in your piece there's a lot of
attitudes have changed around sort of
sexism and abortion and and various
other things like that do you think
that's why it makes such it might make
such uncomfortable viewing for sort of
the bbc it's mainly the character the
homosexual character daniel it it is it
is mainly him as i say he's he's he's
very important in the book and and he
made even more important daniel massey
steals the show in some ways
on
many occasions throughout
the the the
the titular star michael bryant off the
screen
and you couldn't cut it out now but if
you left it in i can just see the sort
of people who like making trouble about
that sort of thing making trouble
people have to understand that the left
back in 1970 the 1960s left was was but
mainly uh still very much more a
communist and the marxist sort of left
the kind that sartre understood it
didn't have the same sexually
revolutionary positions that it has now
female comrades were still expected to
make the tea and savages for the
demonstrations and so forth and
everything that went with that for
instance and attitudes towards
homosexuals and other minorities were
still i think pretty it's suffused with
the with the prejudices of the sort of
sort of society it was then and that
wouldn't translate well into the
into this decade do you still think the
show has sort of value today though for
us then if it is sort of very very
different types i think so i think i say
the the books i i greatly appreciated
the books i hear this this is an actual
souvenir from the 1960s this is i see
from the fly leaf that i gave it to
myself on my birthday in 1968 five
shillings which some idiot will
translate as 25 p it's a wholly
different currency in a wholly different
world and the 1960s are
an era which people find increasingly
difficult to imagine if they weren't in
them even i who was in them have
difficulty in believing a lot of what
took place part of the reason i wanted
to watch the series was was to see how
how my memory actually fitted with with
reality and it is it's
extraordinarily evocative not least
because it contains so much brilliant
acting talent and of course it's like so
many things in the 60s it's a wonderful
film of romeo and juliet which has the
same atmosphere you feel very strongly
that this is at the end of the
at the end of the old culture when
people were still making things who
understood about shakespeare and the
classics in a way they no longer do it
has a very strong quality of having been
made by highly educated people of a kind
who've almost entirely disappeared from
among us it's very nostalgic and and
rather moving from that point of view
and i wish that other people could see
it but i can't i can't arrange for that
to happen
you mentioned your piece it sort of
breaks with the puritanical morality of
the day do you think it could have the
same impact today or do you think it's
more of an interest to sort of as a as
an insight into the decade of the 60s
more in that way well no it has a
reverse impact because it's quite
obvious that the the the the sergeant
character matteo de la rue is is quite
is quite squeamish about the possibility
of of obtaining the abortion he spends
most of the first few episodes trying to
get for his mistress he recognizes that
it's an act of destruction well these
days of course abortion on the left is a
sort of sacrament and a woman's right to
choose and all the rest of it i'm not
sure that would go down very well either
uh the the the position of the women in
in
in the drama is also
one which i think a lot of modern
feminists would find would find made
them rather uncomfortable the references
to drugs are pretty pejorative as well
uh the lola montero the the the
chanteurs who is a major character and
sings laurite
is ruining her life with cocaine quite
evidently and there's there's not much
scruple made about that and you
mentioned in the beginning there that
you um
you did manage to see your screenings
these sort of various clandestine
methods and can you tell us a bit about
that or you can tell us about that
nothing at all no my my lips are whole
is sealed
i can't reveal anything about it at all
you weren't snuck into the bbc
headquarters in about in a diplomatic
bag kind of thing
you can't you can't tempt me i i'm just
not going to tell you
fair enough i'd be wrong
enormous good fortune in in in seeing it
but i i wish i could share it with other
people but i can't and do you have any
hope that it will be maybe if you make
enough noise about it someone will
approach you on a street caller one
evening and say
i have here a copy of the rest of
freedom you want to watch it but maybe
they won't do i mean do you have any
hope at all that it will ever be
released or is that a bit of a pipe
dream at this stage
i think that the problem is that
although i think that the objections to
showing it are stupid
uh they're they're they're also wise
because the the
you can see why somebody would say i
don't really want to wish i don't really
want to risk
the
the the possible fuss that would be made
about showing this by people who don't
understand it and don't want to
understand it and just want to make a
fuss there are i think a lot of people
who will travel a long way in modern
society to be offended by something
and this would give those people such an
opportunity and you can see why people
sitting down in the community if they've
got the freedom to say and they have the
freedom of course
to say that they won't screen it then
the chances are they'll take the easy
option and leave it in the archive
please mr next question which is you
know do you think anything like it could
be made today
not a chance
i the the the people don't exist at the
the sort of talent as i say the the the
level of education and understanding of
classical training uh that went into it
uh the and also the the audience that it
was aimed at who were also considered to
be
educated and informed in a way that
audiences aren't these days
don't exist it's it's a relic of another
era that's another reason why it's so
moving to watch it brilliant thank you
very much peter and uh before you go
we've spent the day at the spectator
trying to track down even just a clip of
this television show we even contacted
the director's family but to no avail
but we have managed to get hold of which
is available online the show's title
track and music which was composed by
the director himself so we're just going
to play that now for you
[Music]
you